solve for is equal to log base B of 81
for B so let's just remind ourselves
what this equation is saying this is
saying if I if I raise B to the fourth
power then I'm going to get 81 let me
rewrite that so if I raise B that's our
base so if I raise our base B I guess
that's why they picked B B for base if I
raise B to the fourth power
I'll do the fourth power in orange if I
raise B to the fourth power that is
going to be equal to 81 I've just
rewritten this equation this logarithmic
equation I've rewritten it as an
exponential equation so it says B to the
fourth power is equal to 81 and we still
need to solve we need to still solve for
B so you just have to think what number
you have to multiply by itself four
times in order to get 81 and 81 you
might jump out of you it is a perfect
square we know that 9 times 9 is equal
to 81 or we know that another way to say
that it is 9 squared is equal to 81 but
we have to raise something to the 4th
power
but 9 itself is 3 times 3 9 itself is 3
times 3 so 1 9 is 3 times 3 and then you
multiply it by another 9 that's another
3 times 3 that will also be equal to 81
and we can verify it 3 times 3 is 9
9 times 3 is 27 27 times 3 is 81 so this
is 3 to the 4th power 9 squared is the
same thing is the same thing as 3 to the
4th power so there we've done it we've
said well some number to the 4th power
is equal to 81 we know that 3 to the 4th
power is equal to 81 so we know that B
that B is equal to B is equal to 3 3 to
the 4th power is 81
or we could say log base 3 of 81 this is
saying what power do I have to raise 3
to to get 81 well we know you have to
raise 3 to the fourth power to get to 81
and if you know about fractional
exponents and don't worry about this if
this confuses you a little bit you could
raise both of these if you know about
fractional exponents and exponent
properties you could do it this way as
well you could take C a B to the fourth
power is equal to 81 you could raise
both of these to the 1/4 power anything
you do to one side of equation you have
to do the other side and from our
exponent properties you know that if you
raise something to a power then raise
that to a power that's like raising it
to the 4 times 1/4 power or this is
essentially just raising it to the first
power so on the left hand side you're
just left with B and on the right hand
side your left is equal to 81 to the 1/4
power but figuring out what 81 to the
1/4 power you really have to go through
this exercise anyway because when you
raise something to the 1/4 power you're
really saying well what what do I have
to multiply what do I have to raise to
the fourth power to get to 81 and then
you get what 81 is to the 1/4 power so
actually this is another way of
realizing that 81 to the 1/4 power is
equal to 3 3 to the fourth power is
equal to 81 81 to the 1/4 power is equal
to 3 but this is the this is you know if
this is confusing to you don't worry
about it for now the important thing is
just you understand what the logarithm
is actually saying what after 8 if I
raise B to the fourth power
I get 81